[Music]
welcome back to careful boys where we
keep it exceptionally pc just in case
careful boys don't get cancelled oh guys
no we need a better uh catchphrase
welcome back to careful boys where we
are very very where we talk about the
things that we are permitted to do this
day and age so we don't
jeopardize what we have left here
hey [ __ ] dave chappelle cheers very
careful yeah that's careful
i'm gonna see him next week let's go
dude hey i don't know if that's norm
mcdonald died
that's a probably good news
[Laughter]
i don't drink the bat
that's probably probably is what gets
paid because that's pretty safe
you leave it up in the air a little bit
hey so you guys been watching squid
games and you guys nope everybody i
refuse it's a very fast why do you
refuse to watch
no i actually i saw the trailer for it
and i'm like damn this is so scary i
can't watch this kind of i've been
traveling i can't watch scary [ __ ] it
does give me harder to watch it gives me
anxiety i have
nightmares that are visceral
and um yeah for us like you can't watch
scary what's up visceral because i know
there's visceral fat and sub you
subcutaneously
i just don't know what this rule um my
nightmares are that i'm routinely
visited by a shadow man who wants to
take over my body and make me kill
myself that's pretty true i had a crazy
night is that a movie no i had so i had
a crazy nightmare i have a crazy
nightmare for those of you guys who are
in long-term relationships i want to
hear what you guys would have done okay
so
my nightmare was in my in my cause this
is something i never consider
in uh in the dream
geo dies right yeah so like like imagine
your wife dying all right people are
your fiance dying i can't even imagine
i've had dreams of geo dying
i wake up and i'm like careful oh [ __ ]
like
what would i do now i could [ __ ] with
our way is is my life does my life
trajectory go the same way because now
it's just me and tyka right yeah i'm
like do i move back to california do i
stay in vegas like not if you drop them
off at the orphanage um stay in
entertainment or do i do do i find a
nine-to-five job because now my
responsibilities are different my
support system is different my entire
the way you you had all this thought
process oh when you woke up oh okay and
i was like oh [ __ ] that's great that's
something i never even consider getting
taxed as a single man is horrible stay
in nevada [ __ ] yeah that's why i'm
gonna get married to a hooker oh cool
that's so smart there's all those
thoughts
all those thoughts
ran through my brain and i'm like that's
[ __ ] crazy because this is like
the like uh emergency that happened or
that's possible that i didn't prepare
for like i got it all over my house i
have backup savings i have all kinds of
things right but like so have you guys
thought of anything like that
i'm not even in your lifestyle right now
but i i'm not talking about three i
think about that i do think about that
so what would like what would you would
you still be doing a personal trainer
would you still honestly i have no idea
i think it's different because i don't
have a kid i think when you have a kid
in there that changes everything yeah so
what joe said drop them off at the
orphanage is probably the only way to go
that's [ __ ] trying to get some puss
pulling you're good i think you're good
no but so
that is pretty crazy
out of all the things we're gonna talk
about today didn't think we're gonna
talk about this about our potential
significant other crazy right
this this over debbie does dallas yeah
yeah maybe maybe let me tell you a happy
story all right i'll tell you what
happened i would have the video playing
no no it's still in context to bart's
thing right you guys know [ __ ] uh
soy tiet yeah 42 43 okay
so my friend manages him you have a dick
on your head by the way all right
so new style so basically um
he has a story just like that
so his
dad
was a singer soy tian's dad he's a
singer and then he was in love and
um
soy they had soy tiat right and um his
mom died of tuberculosis or something
like that
so his dad went into this depression all
this stuff he couldn't deal with it no
more he wasn't making any money so he
had to give soy tia up to the orphanage
but after he did that he couldn't um
face him no more so after that he you
know because his soy tie reminded him of
his of his wife and the family and his
dad just [ __ ] completely outed he
bounced so soy tia
the reason why this fool only got three
teeth and he looks like he's 12 years
old but he's like 30 something yeah is
he's malnourished and he grew up in an
orphanage and and his teeth was rotting
and [ __ ] like that and things weren't
getting fixed and so he stayed in there
for quite some time and all he would see
his friends get like adopted and all
that and he goes one day my time will
come and so during that time he's like
singing and dancing and [ __ ] and doing
his [ __ ] thing right he's counting
the amount of people who haven't adopted
him yeah 44 45
is that where it came from
holy [ __ ] 242
165
you know how high did he get to 3 45
triple digits triple digits infinity
yeah man it was like he's like noah
wanted to adopt him because he was the
ugliest one you know they would adopt
all the other kids but they don't want a
three teeth kid right so he fight his
finds out he's 18 right the orphanage is
like all right you're [ __ ] too old
now you got to find somebody quick
his aunt comes over and then she's like
hey you know what
i'll i'll adopt you and then he's like
when he's 18 i'm gonna have a family
right he's like i'm gonna have a family
and then he gets to the [ __ ] village
and then she goes here's a whip go hurt
them them cattle earn your keep wow yeah
so so he thought he was gonna be like
this fawn family whatever he's just
[ __ ] whipping cattle
a farmhand now farm boy that's it and
then he's learning how to count and seem
and he goes viral boom this one's
learning how to count yeah that's that's
why he made those videos yeah and this
one makes hundreds of thousands of
dollars which is like being a [ __ ]
bazillionaire in his little village good
for him dude he's feeding his village
he's [ __ ] buying all this [ __ ] for
everybody
and then everyone gets jealous of them
wait you said that he
he got adopted at like 18. a little old
and he's like 30 some now so he took him
like 10 plus years to count he counts a
lot counted a lot
he was practicing english yeah yeah just
want to get the timetable but he's
lonely as [ __ ] right because now he's
alienated because he's too successful
and and that the the village peoples
don't like that [ __ ] right so they're
just like hey man you'll take care of us
whatever he's he's literally giving them
so much money like he's buying people
farms and everything but they still
jealous so he's isolated smart people
right so then um he goes to the big city
he meets my buddy he [ __ ] grabs his
hand and he goes i don't know who you
are but i need you to protect me please
don't [ __ ] me over like everyone else
has
and the guy that was managing him just
uh he basically had his instagram
and he was
what my friend found out was that this
dude was taking like 80 [ __ ] percent
of all these things yeah he was taking
mad money from him so then he was like
this is [ __ ] up so he switched over
whatever whatever and then he's like now
he's getting like a salary and he's
making good and then um they're trying
to get him to america
so that's the that's the that's the
happy story but yeah it kind of reminds
me of like that it's like what would you
do if man what a happy story yeah dude
what a turn how's that connected to
geo's death is what i wanted people
significant others like like for example
like let's say you're
um it's you never want it to happen but
like let's say your fiance passed away
right your trajectory the same
with what you have going on is it
exactly the same or does it go
left turn right turn or uh i think my my
trajectory in terms of what i personally
do to like either earn income or like
find stability for myself is the same
but like what i do with that is is
different like i would just um
uh like right now i don't have to like
take care of her parents or anything
like that yeah but i assume i will even
if she stays alive yeah but if she were
to pass then i would probably have that
responsibility somehow subconsciously in
my mind like pushed up i know what steve
would do he'd go on a deep dark
depression no and then and then he won't
even be able to live anymore no the only
way i could i could get by is if i start
two of the timing fans
dude that's that's a dream i haven't
even just to add to that i never had a
dream where she died i only have dreams
or thoughts of when i die what would
happen oh you're so narcissistic
and uh how how that would affect how i
would compile like my will right now i i
know what my will is
you won't get [ __ ] [ __ ]
common [ __ ] everybody yeah my kids only
my wife get that notarized too because
she's playing
you're sucking my dick she deserves
everything what about you
i love them i would yeah i would just
[ __ ] freestyle it bart's [ __ ]
barbara walters on this show this is a
fun scenario dude no i'm just interested
yeah
cuz i've never had this dream until
literally like a week or two ago i don't
know it's crazy it's one of those things
where you think about from time to time
like in your deepest darkest like
thoughts sometimes but then you don't
really play for me at least i don't ever
play out this scenario because you're we
feel immortal no i'm i'm actually on
stage with it where like i play outside
and not not again playing out the
scenario where like my fiance dies but
like i said like i i don't really dream
about my fiance that i have like
daydreams or whatever like if i pass
early what do i do with all my [ __ ] and
the right way to go about it because
then i got i think about like
uh all the things that i own my equity i
think about my partners think about my
parents i think about my sister i think
about her i think about her parents and
i'm like there's a lot of [ __ ] that
needs to be organized right now i'm
naive enough to think like yo i'm like
35 i'm gonna live forever i don't even
have a will dude because exactly
we could die now today's video is
brought to you by
babble
babble is the number one language
learning app right now hands down there
is no competition like them it is pretty
freaking awesome because when i was
going through my journey all throughout
europe i would just download and these
different language apps right and then i
would try to kind of like copy and do
this stuff yeah and none of them really
work thank goodness a lot of the people
out there speak english yeah but i felt
bad because beyond just saying hi and bi
i wanted to show an effort of like hey
i'm really trying to learn your language
and whatever yeah but the apps were
complicated i don't know if i was
pronouncing things right and a lot of it
just was complete garbage and i wish
that i knew babel back then yeah because
babel is super sick they got a speech
recognition software so they'll repeat
back to you and help you fine-tune your
pronunciation so you can actually sound
like you know what you're talking about
and they got this ai that's designed by
over a hundred language experts to help
you learn it the quickest and the most
effective way and there's so many ways
to learn on babble because
not only do they have the speech
recognition and lessons but they also
have podcasts and they make things fun
with like games and videos and things
like that so they really made like
learning into this gamified fun thing
and i think it's definitely there's a
reason why they're the best learning app
right now yeah and all you need is 15
minutes for each lesson so you can
squeeze it in at the gym or on the train
or even if you're in country just on the
subway pop it in learn a few lessons and
it's really easy to learn on the go so
if you're looking to learn a new
language go to babel.com because right
now if you buy three months you get
another three months for free but you
have to use the code off the record go
to babel.com b-a-b-b-e-l.com
use the code off the record to get six
months for the price of three and that's
the best you know why because it takes
about 90
days
to form a habit in six months is plenty
of time for you to break through and get
this acquire this new language yeah and
if you're a good asian boy you probably
learned two languages in that time
that's true do any of you guys think
about that any of you guys have life
insurance i think i do yeah yeah yeah
yeah um
and i should get the most out of all of
us
a fat crypto stack for her but she
doesn't know how to get to it so yeah
that's what i'm saying like brother
though my younger brother knows how to
do all that i trained him to do all that
so that's he's my ace in the hole but
also yeah dude
so the biggest and most serious thing i
can say is that if i lost nikki i don't
even know how i would operate anymore i
told you you'd be depressed i know the
whole world is upside down really
honestly yeah you know you know that's
probably why i don't want to think about
it yeah yeah because we started
exploring so i told you this and then we
just started exploring other scenarios
and i'm like okay what if like
tycho passes away right and i'm like do
we try to make another one i was like
can we try to make another one and then
she was like i don't know and i'm like
whoa that caught me off guard you guys
could adopt because the whole thing just
kind of our whole world is upside down
there's there's stories and i don't mean
to bring this up in a native or whatever
malicious way but there's stories of
couples who are like i see too much of
tyka in you and i have to leave you now
yeah it's like
it's dad it's [ __ ] up it's so you just
don't know what psychology's gonna do to
you that's what i was saying man you
don't know what's gonna happen until
something like that type of like
actually happens trauma happens you know
i mean like yeah it's one of those
things where unless you pre-plan and you
talk about it ahead of time so you can
at least
there's no plan for that though
so you can at least be held accountable
by things that you had discussed in a um
a better state of mind for sure when it
comes to like wills and stuff like that
for sure but at the same time it's like
what am i going to do with the rest of
my life
like if my significant other dies i mean
i don't know i don't know what the
answer to that is you know i mean like
it's one of those things where yeah you
have some plans like contingencies but
that type of stuff it's like like no
hard feelings
my fiance dies i'm gonna do my best to
take over parents and do my best to find
some more [ __ ] dude i will i will
move on
why would you say why do you feel like
you have an obligation to your fiance's
parents though why wouldn't she i agree
i feel the same way yeah why wouldn't
you you know she's your only child
they're my family too like well she's
your only child i'm not just my fiance
not that's i'm dismissing it but i've
known these people for so long now like
for then why do you call them these
people huh i don't like them i don't
like them but i have to take care of
them
uh no but but yeah i mean they can take
care of themselves but i just want to
make sure they're emotionally taken care
of when i when i uh i used to always
address
um
nina's parents as like their
mrs this or mr that or their first name
in a weirdly awkward professional way
yeah and the second we got engaged i
subconsciously allowed myself to call
them like mom and pops
you know what i'm saying so like
weirdest thing that i go through is
telling my
in-laws that i love them because i do
love them but it's the weirdest thing
because you don't feel like you deserve
to tell them that you love them it's
like the most awkward thing is i totally
hear that and maybe that's the the
weirdness of like you know if they were
to pass why do i feel like a
responsibility i don't know the second i
allowed myself to view them as um
surrogate parents and actual family yeah
is the second that they are family
regardless of life or death right like
to like to the end so steve when you
guys when you and nikki first got
married yeah was it kind of weird
initially to call
nikki's parents like mom or dad or
anything you know what's weird uh it
might
nicki will tell you this it's super odd
but
the first time that we met each other i
didn't know nikki because i i was on
youtube
kinda
and nikki was too but i didn't know how
to even watch anything on youtube yet so
i didn't know who nikki was even though
we were in the same sketch group at the
time called toy sketch
and so i met nikki's mom before i even
met nikki even though i guess i met
nikki earlier but i forgot wow but i
remember hitting it off with nikki's mom
that night like she's a sarcastic lady
and she's also like this like
white chick so i never thought it was
nikki's mom wait how did you meet
nikki's mom i was just sitting next to
her at johnny rockets because
it was like after the premiere of this
movie
so she came to support nikki
and then i happened to get seated with
nikki's mom and then nikki was like
roaming with her boyfriend at the time
and i was my chick at the time and like
i just got to see with nikki's mom while
her nicki and her boyfriend time were
chilling and then my girlfriend the time
was like chilling with other people and
i just like was i don't know i like to
just actually sit there and not not like
just say a bunch of [ __ ] i like to
just try to talk to have a real
conversation yeah and she's about crypto
and i was talking about crypto i was
talking about bitcoin in 2013. listen
it's only a dollar right now it's only
bro if you were talking about bitcoins
2013 this is why i call you my crypto
sense i bought bitcoin in 2013 but i
wasn't talking about it dude i'm gonna
buy 800 ethereum check this out y'all
for five bucks
[ __ ] you man i'm sorry i'm sorry
is the only soft spot he has it's the
only soft spot i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry you're doing great now you're
doing great thank you uh no but but
nikki's mommy we really hit it off and
so it's funny because i when i when i
found out when i actually went to her
house i was like oh my johnny rockets
yeah it was like the weirdest thing like
almost like i dated her mom yeah you
went to you went to her house for her
mom not her no no was it was her mom
shot like wait that's the guy or did she
already know she already knew because
nikki like what the [ __ ] yeah yeah
how do you know her yeah well no i
at that point yes but but nikki's mom
already knew that i was the guy that she
talked to johnny rockets because she
remembered me and nikki sent her
pictures and stuff but then it was like
weird as [ __ ] and like i swear i just
already knew these people like it's the
weirdest coolest thing and her old man
her old man hated every guy she brought
in that house and her old man tells me
he loves me all the time he hugs me he
just wants to hang like he's he's a
great man too he's a great man did you
get him in the crypto i did
and he bought ethereum
at 35
whoa he loves me he loves of course he
loves you
holy [ __ ] that's awesome i'll give a
[ __ ] of a dj ex-boyfriend comes in from
my daughter's house and you [ __ ] tell
me you buy ether [ __ ] 30 bucks your
family yeah
you guys can break up in your family
you're my will dude
dude when i told him that i sent his
daughter to las vegas recently
using staking awards for crypto he was
like
that's so hot dude yeah dude i'm soaked
i'm [ __ ] soaked it's always cool when
you could get along with the family oh
i'm a good person
i guess the most important and my my my
um my brother-in-law dane is like the
best dude like i'm so i feel just lucky
because i i had i have brothers i have
two two younger brothers my brothers
nate and kenny and they're i love them
and i love my my older sister who's hot
as [ __ ] but my brother-in-law dane
is like are you not my sister is hot he
let's go
[Applause]
finally so would you put your best in 10
seconds yeah for like an hour can we
just keep it wholesome
like just keep it back
10 seconds pause you know it's
irresistibly hot yeah let's just say
she's not in the negatives anymore
but no i just feel lucky to even know
these people i feel like they are my
family as much as my family my family
and so it's just great and so if i ever
lost nikki that would that link would
not be severed i love these people
that's amazing that's cool yeah very
lucky though because i know a lot of
in-laws are like a nightmare and stuff
yeah yeah actually immediate family is a
nightmare too [ __ ] yeah bro
my aunts and uncles can kill themselves
i don't care
i always tell them i always tell jio's
mom i'm like i love you more than my own
mom and she's always laughing and she
thinks i'm a joke about my now not
really no i'm not but seriously you
can't choose the family that you wish
sometimes no i didn't how much i relate
to that that's like the third uh leading
cause of divorce is in-laws right yeah i
think it's like a third or fourth it's
like it's way the [ __ ] up finance and uh
in-laws yeah because that's my mom
schooled me on that ages ago she goes yo
girls that you date don't just go for
pretty like if you want long term look
at their family study them carefully
because you want them to [ __ ] be cool
so i was like okay that's some of the
best advice you could ever give you yeah
you're not marrying her you're marrying
her family i will say i'm really lucky
um uh nina's mom
is the biggest kindred fan issue really
yes
what does she think about the japanese
[ __ ] you she knows more about kendra's
than nina does it's great
she's the one who like
annoyingly up keeps nina on kin just
happening really hi
do you know blah blah blah blah blah
right you know kendra's aren't costco
now that's annoying to who not to you oh
not to you
baby she must hate me then huh sometimes
she loves you
but she knows who you are
she knows cuties now she knows who you
are sometimes my family likes her stuff
though it kind of backfires because
jio's brother like watches all of our
stuff and when we have family gatherings
half of them are like cholos and just
for fun like he'll just play like old
[ __ ] like me and joe dressed up like
it's the uncles and [ __ ] and they're
just playing and then everyone's like
hey what's up what's that who are you
listening to you like check it out it
goes hey that's not full right there
right there
scary sentence you guys are all talking
[ __ ] on geo
every day
go to school
[Music]
you